[Applause]
I feel like we're we yeah we you wear
your skirt and I'll wear my skirt we
didn't even plan that that's
coordinating you're back on West End
right doing theater do you love theater
I do I do there's something so special
and you know what with the live audience
and when you start you can't stop you
just got to roll with it that's what I
love about it yeah me too because it's
and it's always different right like
every show is different based on
people's moods or if they're tired or
sometimes the audience is super quiet
and you're thinking oh God hate me other
times they really loud and laughing and
you just got to like sometimes though
when they're cuz I noticed that when I
toured and I was younger I was like why
are they so quiet I must have sucked but
they're being respectful and they just
like listening yeah they like listen
Canadian audiences can be like that
they're like very respectful and I'm
from Texas so I'm like where are you
know when that's why I'm like hating
them I'm like come on guys like how bad
did that suck um no but you you bike in
London a lot which I think is crazy
because there's so many cars it's like
here in New York cuz people bike here a
lot I have friends that are I want to do
the electric bike thing you can just
rent them you yeah that's what I do yeah
oh that's what you do and so there's
zero effort you can cycle you can get
that quick as there is a lot of effort
of not dying not dying is something to
think about yeah yeah something to put
in the equation yes no but I love it and
those electric bikes are everywhere in
London now like they're everywhere here
too I'm just I'm a little I kind of want
to like go to a bike path and like rent
it there and just do it there yeah
that's good but also the thing I don't
like about electric bikes is people
aren't wearing helmets now which I've
been and then I think that's really
dangerous I'm going to wear a helmet I
really like my life yeah me too yeah
yeah I priz my life I'm like I don't
want to die now um you grew up with two
brother so that's fun but were they were
you Rowdy like them were you kind of
more of a tomboy I was a tomboy yeah I
was a tomboy anything they could do I
could do better yes Get Your Gun we yes
exactly um yeah in fact the thing they
were most annoyed about with me was that
I love musical so much so I was always
singing so they would just be like that
that was how I could really get to them
was just singing I think I annoyed my my
mother like that now she's fine with it
but like at the time she was like shut
up yeah no but my dad was always making
crazy assault courses in the garden
we're really close in age and and I look
back at Family Videos now and it's
actually kind of like ropes between
trees really high up and he like go go
and it's like wow that was oh my things
I did as a child I would never allow my
kids to do which is not good I mean I
let them be adventurous but I'm like no
you're not doing that yeah they're like
let's get on a dirt bike I'm like or I
just don't want to go to the ER so
um it just seems like a trip right
anyway um you have strong women in your
family I heard that actually your
grandma escaped the Nazis in France yeah
that's red I know she oh she's
incredible she actually passed away has
recently passed away but she's French
Marinette oh and um yeah she was 11
years old lived in France when during
the second world war and and the Germans
took over her home and she was on the
road she was bombed at she went on this
Mass kind of Exodus to Paris so her
stories it's just so incredible i' sit
with her and you just realize I what she
lived through and have been through and
I mean would you ever make a film about
that cuz that seems pretty great I know
and she wrote down so my grandfather she
spoke all all her memories and my
grandfather wrote it into like a small
book so it is something I would love to
do one day yeah I think that's amazing
especially if you have like your own
production company and you can like
really take hold of it because it's the
ownership is your family yeah exactly it
would have to be really precious and
take care of it and make sure he right
but and you could play your grandmother
that's like amazing um I want to shout
out to my other grandmother as well
America actress just incredible Helen
Horton the most glamorous powerful woman
so oh God so you're from just a powerful
yeah a good
breed that's amazing yeah and now I want
to shout out to my mom cuz she'll be
like you always mention your
grandmothers my mom's amazing too Mom
you are amazing mom well done mom I get
I get that my mom would totally so do
you are you like the family heirloom
type do you all have a weit I didn't
know anyone in my family so I have like
barely anything from my family are you
the type to keep stuff we do have
heirlooms we do well there's like I but
I'm so sentimental I'll keep anything
like a tiny note that someone's written
to me once it's like all stored away I'm
such a hoarder I am the complete
opposite of you I wish I was like you
well I feel like we had the moment and
then you let it go right you've got to
let go cuz I am like my emotional state
becomes chaotic if there's a lot around
I like simple like yeah I'm chaotic oh
my God to no I am chaotic that's why I
need it like I mean I do like like nck
exist to some point but like it's yeah I
get over overwhelm but I we don't really
have a lot of family heirm so yeah
that's cool um remodeling um I heard
you're doing that in London I love
Renovations you do I love design I love
all of it I bought this house and I was
so excited you know and I it's Regency
it's super old I think it's like 250
years old so I thought it had tons of
character and it does but it's really
just falling apart I was going to say
all all I heard was mold yeah damp mold
everything yeah um you can fix that and
restore like to the original kind I love
that but there's load bill just came up
to me the other day looking sort of like
really suspicious and they and they'd
found under the floorboards I was like
God what are they going to found it's a
really old house this could be something
really interesting and they found like a
couple of old like like well-worn porno
magazine pamplets and and they were
under the floorboards and they looked at
me like real suspicious I was like these
are from the 70s like what do you think
I wasn't even a lie yeah but I just love
the idea of you hiding porn like 70s
porn in your floorboards my that's
totally could be your thing that's
creepy uh let's get to some I mean if
you're that that's my thing if you have
to hide it maybe you shouldn't be doing
it what anyway let's get to some do you
world now look at the in theaters right
now so your character is actually based
on a real person does that does that
create more stress for you yeah of
course cuz you want to do them Justice
and you want them to sort of like you
know feel seen and you want to represent
them well but um with this I know that
recently they had the LA premere and Pam
and Kevin with their and they I think
they loved the film and they had an
amazing moment with all the cost and but
actually that was one of the things that
was most beautiful
about so I'm I um Kevin's girlfriend
then become wife they fall mly in love
and and in real life they're still
together they liveed through such tra
tragedy and adversity which you see in
in the movie and they're still together
I think they are they've you know fought
for their love and they've created a
whole new family and I think that's so
inspirational and we wanted to you know
pay homage to that
and cuz it's intense the film is intense
it's intense yeah I mean even right
there he's well he's beaten up you need
to like give him words yeah explain to
everybody like what the movie is about
yeah so it's um it's about the von Eric
family they were this Texan family um
all boys all wrestlers following in the
footsteps of their father and they
started out as underdogs uh in the
wrestling world and they like they
fought their way their way up to the top
they were kind of rock stars you know
and they created this you know American
sport Dynasty and but but the film
tracks that rise and their Triumph but
along the way there's just unspeakable
tragedy it's almost like a Greek tragedy
what that family go through so um and
Kevin played by Zack Efron who is
exquisite he is so incredible in this
film is sort of through his eyes um he
looks different speaking of eyes like I
was I was like oh my God like he looks
so was it startling to like go on set
and be like okay yeah I could barely
recognize him there was so much more of
him I mean he was huge
he was I mean those boys worked so hard
and the wrestling you see in the film
it's legit them doing it like I've never
seen anything like it it was so
impressive I'm exhausted thinking about
it that's I know I was so grateful I
could just sort of sit on the sidelines
for this one and just like let them do
the hard body slam anyone yes um well
the mo the movie deals with family
Dynamics and getting I love you so much
and and getting through like hard
situations so how did you relate to that
is your family pretty easy or I mean I
think
well your family are the people that get
you through the tough times aren't they
and the people that you rely on and lean
on and so I'm pretty sure everyone has
had experiences where they've had to
really absolutely you know yeah and
they're the ones who have to call you
out call them out yeah yeah exactly you
you trust them to sort of have your back
and keep you in line and and be there
for you in times are tough so I
definitely am so grateful I have an
amazing family that's awesome well
definitely the women we've talked about
so well speaking of another movie thing
that I love that you're in um Mama Mia
um do you think you do m a three cuz I
just had share here and we were talking
about I don't know if we talked about on
camera off camera but we were talking
about it about Mama M3 and I was like I
feel like you should do it yeah I wanted
you do it I okay do you cuz did you grow
up singing first because you're very
comfortable in that area yeah I always
loved singing and dancing that was my
first love and I just I wanted to do
musicals and then I ended up doing more
acting but I that I'd seen Mama Mia so
many times as a kid and I and I was
obsessed so that that show that role was
like this crazy like dream come true mad
moment I couldn't believe it was real
full circle full circle kind of moment
and um yeah great songs great dancing it
was really fun I would love to do the
next one I think it should be about how
the D dynamos Don and the dynamos formed
which is my idea but mainly because then
I could be in it but it's also a good
idea cuz mainly I want to be in it but I
think that's an actually really good
idea oh that's amazing so wait so if you
were to play cuz a biopics are a huge
thing now like if you were to play like
a musician who do you think you would
play who or who would you want to play
well I there was there's two there's two
sort of versions of the answer whenever
I Karaoke I do Shia Twain so there's
like that's oh you would be great you a
Southern accent
now you just have to make it a little
Canadian yeah but then I also love
Janice jop planam which would be the
more like hog call
like I don't know if I could do it but
you'd wreck your voice doing it but you
do yeah you gotta do something you got
to drink a lot to get there yeah yeah I
love I love her as well she's Texan I'm
pretty sure yeah I love her as well if
she's not Texan I just owned her yeah
she is I'm pretty sure yeah I was going
to say I think she was all in cool
people are um let's take another break
everybody the iron claws in theaters
[Music]
now
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home